[Musique]
jeudi
alors qu'ils devraient alors pour faire
une trop de cartes il faut que c'est un
kart
alors je vois guère vous faire très
nette gens vont en revanche se dégrader
beaucoup alors il est possible que la
dégradation du quartier en train de la
dégradation du bistrot de quartier que
la renaissance ou la prédation ou les
sauveurs parce que un bistrot de
quartier qui peut être préservée qui ont
amusé à john un plus on serait
stationnaire pendant que je vais en
faire des petits mont saint michel à
usage intime bien générer dit non à un
petit c'est à dire amener à voir mais on
s'arrêtait pas maintenant on a le temps
avant travailler tous les jours
tous ces gens qui vont dans la vie dans
la ville en bramant qu'ils sont
orphelins que l'environnement cherche un
petit environnement une famille où moi
je viendrai a senti à 100 d'air d'ici
mais nous tous vos intérêts tu marche à
l'électricité atomique il avait un robot
ça c'est l'ambiance de tous mes clients
qui viennent
racontent leurs petites histoires des
fois sont défectueuses vol inconfortable
on peut vous raconter les vôtres c'est
aussi également est ce que vous les avez
eu quelquefois l'idée d'installer
machine à disques à mon amie américaine
n'est pas la place déjà puis toute façon
ça fait 3 de boues rire sans valeur
l'essentiel c'est qu'on puisse discuter
complice discuté et j'ai des personnes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à café de biens français à celle à moi
retrouve le plus de sympathie et seul
café bien français whissell a encore
beaucoup des métiers comme ici paris
quand comme ici par exemple on fait pas
de différence ni pour la nitro d'accord
pour le prouvent ni pour le riche que
tout le monde est ami ou toujours des
comptes en famille enfin pour toi tu
obligé de nous corriger nous parler
avant dans les cafés ont retrouvé
beaucoup de cafés où tout le monde se
réunissait pour jouer à la belote pour
et ça se perd de plus en plus jacky le
domino et d'amour
j'aime bien jouer aux dames mais pour
trouver un cheveu un café ou un jour de
maintenant marché vous pouvez faire tous
les cafés y apprend john m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le petit charles onians ne peut plus
vivre les grossistes le mange comme
toutes les maisons bouffer les petits
commerces et on a beau se bagarrer c'est
exactement pareil
le petit chat louis leblanc boublil à
partir de marge bénéficiaire pour
arriver à vivre îlotiers disparaître on
arrive à se défendre parce qu'on fait
puisque le charbon par exemple où il
fait le café est quand même rentable
bourg où on est dans des quartiers où on
travaille quand même un peu à limonade
et ça nous sommes donc revenus même pas
mes enfants je veux pas parler métier là
j'ai un fils qu'il a 17 ans et qu'un sac
de charbon parce que c'est la mode
autrement jamila pendant ces métiers là
pourtant sa future mon métier mais ce ne
l'est plus vous ferez pas de commerce
que ce que vous ferez je remets était
chauffeur livreur comme j'étais avant
le briani chez nous parce que ménard qui
a ravagé
[Musique]
paradoxe on n'est jamais tout à fait
vivre quand on quitte un bistrot de
quartier et on est déjà huit cantons
ayant tellement c'est simple
[Musique]